[Music]
my name is Vincent I'm from fighting
Amsterdam and today I will talk to you
the name of the talk is SAS sampling as
a algorithm service and what I will talk
to you about there basically the joy of
sampling algorithms how they work why
they work and when you should actually
use them so in short I'm going to first
explain sampling methods as a concept
it's always important that we understand
the concept and once we've understood
the concept I'm going to show you how to
build the concept in a simple Python for
loop and I'm going to sort of get into
the depth and explain that this concept
is also useful for machine learning
we're going to apply the concept to a
kegel problem we're going to apply the
concept to a time series task and then
I'm going to compare the performance of
this sampling approach to something we
build up in tensorflow so very simple I
mean most of us have probably seen this
example before the best sort of idea of
explaining sampling is usually by doing
this task assuming you've gone to a
college where sort of you're doing
programming for the first time you've
probably done this exercise we're trying
to estimate pi and you do that by
drawing a circle and the circle is
between one by one square you draw a
random points within this one by one
Square and at some point you have enough
points that you can estimate pi because
the relationship between the area of the
square and the area of the circle is
such that you can derive PI from it I'm
assuming people have seen this exercise
before and I'm assuming that this is
something you know of sampling is a way
of getting sampling right and if you do
this often enough then you get a nice
measurement of pi what's cool though is
this is sort of what I would call direct
sampling occur you have a space and
directly sampling from it but
alternatively what you could also do
just as a concept as you can say you
know instead of sort of sampling
directly how about I just pick a random
point somewhere and sort of like a frog
I hop around and if I do this forever
and I keep hopping around in the search
space I might also just estimate pi well
so if there's a second sub shell idea it
also do the frog hopping and so let's
get a Markov chain going then your
thought at the moment might be hey that
seems logical but something might go
wrong here namely you know the Frog is
going to eventually jump outside of the
square so we need to do something about
that so there's these boundaries I'm the
only one Explorer
agents that we are interested in and we
can't have our poor pebble go to
infinity we may need to twiddle a bit
and sort of think about the mark of
stepping rule if we really want to
estimate pyro we have a direct sampling
approach so we need to find a way to get
this indirect sampling approach to work
so there's two ways of doing this I
guess I mean one way would be if the
pebble jumps out on the left side we
make it reappear on the right side
there's one thing we could do but
there's a bit of math involved you want
to prove it an alternative might also
just be instead of going out to the left
how about we stay where we are and then
sample a point which might be in the
region we like so I hope at least we get
we have two ways of sampling and if we
do this
then we'll also get 2pi so we have a
direct way of sampling and with indirect
way of sampling this is the first
concept we need to have in our heads
before we move on to higher levels of
extraction but we can use the REC
sampling or indirect sampling to get an
estimate of pie out this indirect
sampling won't be as random initially we
kind of have this we need to have this
chain be very long before we actually
get something that's sort of nice and
random enough but if we do this for
let's say millions of times then at some
point this will be random enough so we
can get an unbiased estimate of a pie is
so we've just seen them run a sort of a
Markov chain being used in for value of
interest so let's see if we can maybe do
this for other values because this is an
example with pie maybe let's start doing
some more data scientist stuff instead I
hope the main concept is clear though we
can use a Markov chain to get variables
we want from interest instead of doing
that with PI let's now assume that I
have some data points and in assuming
that this data comes from a normal
distribution and I would really like to
discover what normal distribution data
might have come from and for those of
you who might need a bit of mathematical
remember remembrance remember that the
normal distribution is two parameters a
mu which says where is the center of my
normal distribution and a sigma which
says how sort of skewness or to the
tails or how peaky is it hi Sigma means
there's lots of variance low Sigma means
there's low variance so instead of
getting samples for sort of a region
where I'm trying to estimate PI from
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
sample values from you and
before I had sort of an X and a
y-coordinate on a sample now I'm going
to sample around in the MU and Sigma
space because the idea is if I sample
around I also might get an idea of what
a good estimate for MU is and a good
estimate for Sigma and what I'm doing
this I also want in mind being able to
quantify the Mew and Sigma and the
randomness I would have so same idea
let's just pick a random value of means
somewhere and random value of Sigma
let's do a Markov chain in the parameter
space and as there is lots and lots and
lots and lots of times and we get this
chain with lots of these values and
again you could wonder what might go
wrong here and the exact same thing is
with the PI example because if you think
about if we're sampling such a thing
this is the RADS of the Markov chain you
might get let's say we start over here
and at some point we end up in a space
where Sigma is negative obviously that's
a lot of Sigma is never going to be
negative there will never be a normal
distribution where there's no variance
whatsoever so if you just sample
randomly just like before it might leave
a region of interest and we neither
think of a way that we can prevent this
so what might be a nice way for us to
stay clear of areas we don't like
because we don't mind sampling in areas
that are likely but we don't a sample as
many times as in areas that are not
likely so we need a kind of way to score
the sample that we get so how about I'm
standing here and I'm considering going
there
I'm the pedal I'm about to jump if the
score that I have now is less than a
score that I will have then probably
next sample is rather likely and I
should always do the jump if where I am
right now and this next step seems to be
going the less likely direction we
should maybe consider standing still and
exploring a different area so I'm now
using a concept of a score and what is a
good score well so in this example right
we have a couple of data points and
we're going to figure out what a nice
view or a nice signal might be and I'm
assuming it comes from a normal
distribution
how about I take all the data points
that I have I map that to the normal
tribution that I'm currently considering
and I just multiply all these likelihood
values if this is a good estimation then
most of the likelihood should be in an
area that is sort of likely selecting
another that measurement maybe and again
I'm standing right here is am unit Sigma
I'm moving to the next area where
there's a different unit different Sigma
and I need a way to say this point is
better or worse than that point so this
is a score you could get this is a
normal distribution this is sort of the
likelihood that we have that we get this
data given that if we have a certain mu
in a certain Sigma and here we have a
slightly different view and a slightly
different Sigma and you'll notice that
the likelihood score do we get out is
slightly different the y axis will
change in the next picture but let's say
I now have a light blue that is very
broad the likelihood might actually get
worse as well okay let's take this
likelihood approach I haven't had done
any full math proofs it's also not my
goal this talk but we have a nice way to
say hey the current place of the pebble
is better or worse than the next place
of the pebble and we could sort of
compare so we're still sampling that's
the idea but we still need this roughest
course a bit and this seems like a nice
path to go onto so we can calculate the
score now we at least discovered what
the score should be let's now maybe make
it more tangible with an example so
let's say I have some parameters a
that's where I'm now and I have some
parameters B which is where I might be
going we need to find a way to say hey
when do I jump to B and when do I stay
in hey how about we just compare the two
scores so we do a coin flip if it's
twice as likely that I should stay as
opposed to going I do a coin flip if
it's below 0.5 or something like that I
stay otherwise I go now I've told kind
of like a very quick fairy tale of how I
might do this so let's do a bit of recap
because I just discussed quite a bit we
have some data and we have some
parameters we want to estimate and we're
going to use sampling we're going to do
nothing fancy we're just going to do
sampling we're going to sample around
the MU and Sigma space so those are the
the two numbers I need to define a
random distribution that is more
all the way we're going to sample we're
going to say hey starting from some you
in some Sigma if the next mu and Sigma
is more likely do a move if not compared
to likelihoods that I have flip a coin
and then decide to stay or whoops decide
to go I'm just going to repeat this a
whole lot of times the hope is that at
the end I will have lots of immune
samples a lot of Sigma samples and this
mu value that's more likely will also
appear more often that way I might be
able to infer what the true mu should be
and the easiest way to demonstrate that
this actually works is to just build a
for loop in Python so let's coat this up
first I did is just import numpy and I
import stats I make some random numbers
just so I have my starting data that I
start out with I make an array with one
element that the is going to hold all
the mule values at our sample and I have
another way array with one element
that's going to hold all the Sigma
values that I have I'm also going to
find a step size the step size nothing
more than something to say hey this
pebble that I have how big will the
jumps be that the pebble is going to
make and here is a function that's kind
of nice which comes out at sy pi they
just calculate the likelihood the only
thing I do is I take the data given mu
and a Sigma a map that's to the normal
distribution and that just gives you my
likelihood number that I can use to
compare the score with this in place I
just build a small for loop basically at
every single time i say hey i have a new
mu which is the old mu plus some sort of
random step and i have the old
likelihood i have the new likelihood and
then i'm just going to say hey it's this
new number more or less likely if so if
it's more likely always make the jump if
it's less likely to a coin flip and if
we fail the coin flip then just append
the old number we can do this and then
we have a nice array of MU we have a
nice array of Sigma and I can show you
what sort of the results look like in
the beginning we were sampling mu in an
area that's not really likely and then
BOOM at some point we keep on staying an
area that is actually kind of likely and
this is what happens over time so this
is many many different iterations many
many different random numbers and this
is one
way of looking at it namely over time we
can also take a sum of this and then
turn it into a histogram again in the
beginning we were exploring this area
but more and more later on we're
exploring this area I'm actually kind of
nice because I can almost immediately
see like hey maybe the maximum likely
the very likely value for the average is
around here and also get a nice
impression of how uncertain I might be
that this is the actual sort of true
value from you and as I'm doing this
from you I'm also doing this for Sigma
and again I'm starting out in some
region that's probably not very likely
and it only tries to be in regions where
it's more likely and then it's at some
point simply gets seems to be sampling
in the same area over and over again and
I get the same sort of distribution for
Sigma another way of looking at this
it's not to say hey let's just look at
Sigma let's just look at MU but we can
also do is you can say let's look at how
mu and Sigma change over time and I
started mu and Sigma sort of in the
region that's not very likely and you
see it explore different regions and at
some point it determines that hey maybe
I should keep around here typically
you're not very much interested in what
happens at the beginning when you're
doing such a sampling approach so to
make things simple how about we just cut
away the first 1000 samples we have a
focus on we did later and then wind up
with something like this
we have still some uncertainty of what
the true value of MU might be in with
the true value of Sigma might be but we
seem to have quantified that uncertainty
in a way so with this very simple photo
we've actually demonstrated a couple of
cool things we've just demonstrated the
idea behind sampling algorithms the idea
is you just think of a mathematical
system that describes your uncertainty
so if you make a model probabilistically
and then just sample such that you're in
areas that are likely more often than
there is that you're not and with that
very simple idea you can actually build
lots of models and you just use sampling
to come to your model a couple of
benefits that our implementation right
now so a couple of facts let's say it's
another benefit our implementation is
not very fast I mean I just wrote a
small for loop it's appending to a list
we might be doing something better
refraction no types so probably it's
best if we use a specialized package
instead of doing this with four loops if
I'm a data scientist I might want to do
something more mature than right for
loops in my notebook so probably we
should use a package and we may not need
to talk more about practical examples
because in this case of course you could
just take the mean by taking a sum and
divide by number numbers in the array so
this is the first thing I did as I was
trying to learn what sampling algorithms
do and this has a point in between
whenever you're trying to learn
something is what I learned from
analyzing how I was learning this
whenever you do not understand an
algorithm build it yourself and make it
as simple as possible quite often when
you're learning a new algorithm all it
takes is a for loop or to try to write
code that you love reusing as well
simple helper functions like the
likelihood function that I made they
make sure that you know make unnecessary
mistakes especially if the algorithms
new debugging is kind of hard and what I
do when I do this sort of thing I have a
separate cell in my notebook that
there's nothing else but have a few
assert statements just to make sure that
the functions I build in between aren't
the thing that aren't the thing that
makes the error it's very annoying if
you don't know if the numerical aspect
is a problem or the code that you've
just written this is just a mere point
in between and I want to jump back to
the fact that it actually may have
gotten a nice algorithm to do data
science in so let's discuss the math a
little bit because you know why is this
so important and why do people care well
the way the Bayesian look at the world
is they say they have this formula that
you've probably seen on blogs somewhere
it's we have some parameters and we have
some data I mean kind of want to do
inference on what might be likely values
of the parameters of the model given the
data that we see and Bayes rule
basically says that that is proportional
to the probability that you see this
data given the parameters times the
prior of your parameters and in our
example I'm using theta here as sort of
a collectible term for all the
parameters that I have in the example we
just saw
that's mu and a Sigma and the funny
thing about this Big D we can also make
that a little bit clearer we can just
say the collection of all the data
points the way you handle that typically
is you say well you can calculate the
probability
that given these parameters this data
put this one data point appeared I can
kind of multiply all the likelihoods
together to come to one single likely a
number and that's the cool trick that
you use to say hey this is one point in
the parameter space before I jumped is
more likely than the other one and you
can do log likelihood tricks here you
don't have to multiply you can also take
the sum of the log but this is also a
nice vantage point and the main cool
thing about sampling is that suddenly we
are very flexible I can come up with any
sort of probability likelihood that I
want I could come up with I can
translate this into a linear regression
or a neural network of whatever I want
as long as I can sample this I can
sample around this space and I have a
likelihood I can do inference all of my
parameters so there's still a little bit
of abstract so let's just do two
examples that show that this might be
useful and because it is a data science
conference we have to have one Kaggle
example so my favorite kaggle
competitions are the ones around
Christmas because then something always
goes wrong at Santa's headquarters in
this particular example Santa has a
thousand bags to fill with nine types of
gifts due to regulations at the North
Pole workshop no back and contain more
than 50 pounds of gifts and the idea is
you don't know exactly how much is one
gift weighs and yes to assign a gift to
a bag if there's too many gifts in the
bag the bag will break however I do get
information back I do know at some point
that this one bag weighted as much which
means I can kind of do inference on what
the gift actually waved because I might
know for example that we had a gift
there was a type horse and if a horse
gift
sort of came from this one distribution
or a trained gift came from this
distribution so I know some things about
these gifts but I can I serve was
wondering if I know the sum of a couple
of bags can I do inference to figure out
what the actual weight of one of these
gifts was and to put that a little bit
more of a math equation suppose that
there are four gifts I know the weight I
know the prior so I have an impression
of what the minimum maximum weight of
one of these gifts might be but I mainly
get the sum of the bag back so in this
situation I could say hey I've got w1
which is the weight of one gift I've got
W to which the way that's another gift
and I only get these things back so I
have a couple of things that I know and
a couple of things that I don't know
so preferably I like to be able to do
inference on this and preferably I don't
want to do this with a for loop so how
do you do that quite simply it's
chugging into PI MC 3 it's a library
that just does this it's very easy you
basically say hey these are the
parameters that I want to do inference
on and these are the data points that
I've actually seen in real life so in
this case I can say hey I've got these
normal valid variable I'm assuming that
mu is normal and the only thing I know
is that mu 1 plus mu 2 is well this is
the observed value that I see but I
don't know exactly what mu 1 or mu 2 is
the only thing I know that when I add
them together I get this one number out
that I knew before so let's have a
pebble and sample sample sample sample
sample and see what we get back Primus
III can make a plot that sort of looks
like this and it's the same thing as we
saw before we can I'm doing multiple
samples here but you can see here the
iterations that I'm making I'm making
lots of them I can see here what we get
over time we do this for the decoder the
few parameters that we have so for the
first gift the second gift the third
gift and the fourth gift and it
shouldn't be too much of a surprise that
it's pretty sure what the weight of the
third and the fourth gift is you can see
that it's very nicely converged this is
kind of logical because there's no four
unknowns and sort of three equations so
it's kind of likely that would really
know the value of two of these things
what is one degree of freedom that's
what you see back here these chains they
are sort of parallel so there's like a
green thing here that's hot that's low
and a green thing there that's high and
every line you see here is from an
independent chain so to say but we can
you don't see the mouse oh I thought you
guys column houses super embarrassing
okay well I thought you saw the mouse
the old-time thanks though so you see
bit of green here and see a bit of green
there right and you see that there's a
bit of blue here and you see the exact
same blue shape here but it's mirrored
which basically means that the samplers
doesn't really know what the value of mu
1 or mu 2 needs to be but it does know
that if this value is low this one
should be
and that's sort of the intelligence we
expect and I was sort of wondering for
this one chiral competition if I submit
a few things to Kaggle can I infer what
the two weights of these gifts were so
that was sort of the main goal I had
I'll show you in a bit that this this
won't work but this is a nice
explanation of how inference works
there's a couple of things that I know
and given any system that I have I just
have to explain the math I can sample
sample sample and just let the the
sampler sort of figure out what the
actual probabilities were there are some
limits to this though so let's say we do
tons of gifts and a few bags so in this
in the previous situation I have four
gifts and three bags and this situation
I have ten gifts and six bags I can push
this into the sampler and then it sort
of gives me feedback that says hey this
is all over the place this is a feature
though because the sampler at this point
does tell me hey I am totally not sure
what the weight of this variable is I
can give you a maximum likelihood number
but what I'm also giving you is sort of
a nice distribution that describes my
uncertainty and I don't know about you
but I like knowing about my uncertainty
this is typically what makes Bayesian
stations we care about this sort of
thing so there's a little bit of a
hypothetical example I think right so
this is a nice skagle thing but what
might be in this sort of a situation
where you know it's obvious that we're
doing something that's useful so let's
consider the switch point problem if
it's a problem I'm not saying it's the
obvious problem for this sort of
research but it's a nice problem because
people can typically understand it let's
say you have a computer system you have
lots of servers everywhere and a change
happened at some point in time you want
to know when the change happened and you
can do this manually by plotting that
and then saying hey the change probably
happened there but probably want to
automate this because you have thousands
of thousands of servers and humans are
kind of expensive to pay to check all
this in this situation we need to define
a mathematical zuv a public system and
it's just like before I'm interested in
fine fearing what my parameters were
given some data set that I have
except in the previous case I had a mu
and a sigma or weight of a bag and in
this case I have a switch point mu
before the switch point mu after the
switch point a Sigma before the switch
point and a Sigma after the switch point
this is the mass but I can also explain
it with the picture in which people
typically prefer so given a towel which
denotes where was a switch point I could
say hey this part belongs to first
system is part belongs to the second
system and I'm assuming that all data
comes from a normal distribution with nu
1 or Sigma 1 on this side mu 2 and Sigma
2 on this side and you know hopefully
we're going to figure out that tau is
more likely to be around here than
around there and you know I can write it
out all in the mass and this is the mass
of the picture you just saw before but
this is the essence of it and the main
thing that we have to be very mindful of
is and don't let the mass confuse you
too much the main thing that we need is
we need to describe the likelihood of
all the day that we've seen given the
parameters and we can split it up into
say a prior of some sorts and let's say
a likelihood of some sort so this is
where we're going to put the model
mainly and the model is actually kind of
simple we just say if the data point Y
is in the before at a switch point then
it comes from one normal distribution
otherwise it comes from the other
distribution the only thing I'm going to
add is I'm going to add some sort of
prior to this as well because I know a
couple of things about the system
beforehand and therefore main point is
that the switch point is an integer that
cannot be shorter than 0 smaller than 0
or larger than the length of the time
series and also know the variance of the
Sigma variable should always be positive
if I ever start sampling in regions that
don't adhere to that rule I'm doing
something bad again this is the same
recipe as I told about the 4 we have
some data and some unknown parameters
we're going to sample around the
parameter space Markov style if the next
parameter sample is more likely we move
if it's not a flipper coin and decide to
stay or move on and we're going to
repeat this a whole lot of times and
also here I'm not going to go through
the effort of doing a for loop
I'm going to use pine c3 instead so I
just say we have a basic model open and
I do something where I say hey there's a
mu and mu 2 and a Sigma 1 and Sigma 2
and a switch point these are the things
that I don't know and on the line below
I will say hey but the I need to involve
the switch points somehow so I'm going
to calculate what the MU is over time by
saying hey if the time is larger than
the switch point use Mew 2 and otherwise
use mu 1 and do the same thing for the
Sigma and the nice thing is I going to
take that mu I can take that Sigma I can
say they came from a normal distribution
I have some observed variables boom go
ahead and sample this is the plot that I
get back and again in the beginning its
sampling in a region that's not super
likely but eventually it gets to a point
where it says hey most likely this is
sort of the posterior distribution of
the parameter space from which I can
easily see hey there's a value of Sigma
1 the value of Sigma 2 and it seems to
be very certain the switch point
happened there
suppose that there was no switch point 5
minutes oh boy suppose there was no
switch point then this would have been a
very uniform distribution however
there's only one single peak here which
means that the we're pretty sure that
the switch point happened there we
should be careful though because if we
now want to say something about what was
the maximum likely value from u 1 u 1
for example the downside would be if we
do a gradient search we might get stuck
in this hill so we care about the
sampling because you know a great insert
in this space might get us stuck but
there's two bonuses there's less chance
for us to getting stuck and we get a
nice view of what the how uncertain we
are about this parameter those are the
main benefits of taking this bayesian
approach let's say and I only have five
minutes so I'm definitely going to go a
bit faster now there's a sorry seven Wow
luxury by extension what we can also do
is we can consider a situation where we
have two switch points and the main
thing that is quickly jot over is that
the system is kind of the same in this
case I'm assuming that we had a
situation before revert to a different
state and then we breathe
from building models if this is
happening and the code is relatively the
same except I have to switch points now
and the view
once you've sampled all of this it gets
a little bit different the main thing
that you see is that it takes a bit
longer now because there's more switch
points and there's more parameters in
general it takes a bit longer before in
the likely area so what you would
typically do is you would say okay if
this is probably unlikely area and we've
seem to have converged here if we're
going to talk about the posterior
distribution maybe we should only look
at the variables and not include the
first bits but just look at the last bit
and things look a bit nicer so I hope
that by now I give you sort of an
intuitive glimpse of why sampling
algorithms are nice and that PI mc3
might be a nice library to play with I
will end on this sort of more critical
conclusion though because we I now
showed you guys all the benefits of
sampling but let's be critical I wonder
can we also do this in a different way
because you can wonder do we need
sampling if this is the mathematical
system that we have I mean I can also
just see this as some sort of function
where these are parameters I have to up
sort of optimize I can also maybe just
say hey do just do gradient descent in
that space I mean we could do the
sampling and you get the posterior and
all that's very nice but if you're just
interested in the maximum likely value
you could maybe just do this in the
parameter search right how about that so
the codes too long to discuss but this
is the code that you need to do this in
tensor board tensor flow and I basically
implemented what I just said in tensor
flow just to see hey is the statement
true can we get similar results just by
doing a gradient search why tensor flow
there's great support for gradient
methods and the logging is for free
because you get tensor board which is
nice so I ran this and every what you
see here is just the likelihood that I
ended up with what you see here is the
value for towel that I found and the Mew
one the Mew 2 Sigma 1 Sigma 2 values you
see that there's a bit of noise and the
reason that there's noise because I'm
doing this on simulated data and
everyone gets a different seed turns out
I keep on hitting the maximum likely
value in this case I didn't get stuck in
a hill
so great the sense works and solve the
problem it may not always work though I
mean you depending on the system you
define there might be a system with lots
and lots of hills and there's a bigger
risk of actually getting stuck I do
think we're fall to mention this though
because in the end there are reasons to
go for the sampling approach and there
are reasons why you might want to go for
the great approach situation for example
where you don't have a lot of data then
you usually have uncertainty and then
you typically want to have a posterior
you want to be able to describe how
uncertain you are absolute numbers
simply because that's my girlfriend some
because you know it's actually kind of
ridiculous oh you guys don't know the
stress that I'm feeling but my
girlfriend just said over the chat that
she's now that I'm not home she gets to
buy whatever she wants she's off buying
a kitten now so when I get back but
thanks by data for extending my family
anyway and if you don't have lots of
data so PI mc3 them has a nice use case
because you want to be very ease and
certainty you want to do something with
your seer distribution and also if you
need to make like one single big
decision so you're going to do sort of a
large simulation and you want to make
one decision where there's lots of risk
involved then - it makes sense because
you want to be very explicit about your
uncertainty but prolific programming in
general only defining a nice
mathematical system and seeing if you
can optimize that and be clever about it
you could use prime c3 but other tools
exists and you might be able to use a
creative as well the goal of this talk
is to give you guys more of an intuition
of how the sampling methods work and to
also give you an impression that these
tools are actually kind of nice to play
with I think I have two minutes maybe
four questions thanks and also like
thanks for listening was this was 85
slides so you guys have been a great
crowd
thanks for sticking around what the two
or two minutes I was for the quo all
right I got we can administer questions
everyone do anyone has a question yeah
so in the first example where you were
talking about finding the mean and Sigma
of a normal distribution given the data
yeah it looked like you were kind of
doing a stochastic gradient percent
approach in there anyway because you're
saying if I'm going to improve my
outcome I'm going to make a decision not
whether to jump that way so yeah but
there's one important distinction
there's still a probability that they go
to a lower or region that's not as
likely a gradient algorithm typically
doesn't do that the reason being in this
case I'm interested in finding the
distribution of uncertainty over my
parameter space gradient search is
typically more interested in finding the
most likely value these two tasks are
different the Bayesian would say the you
know the maximum likely value of my
posterior is not so much a special
citizen I'm interested in the full
distribution this is what makes Bayesian
and machine learning specialists
different typically okay thank you the
one thing that is actually kind of nice
to show as well as a sort of extension
of this because I still have tensor yeah
so I was running this this morning for
those of you not familiar with tensor
board wait a minute there we go so it's
a different screen or is it there we go
so this is the same system as before but
what I've done is I have used different
methods of gradient descent sort of the
check how our different methods of
gradient descent and all such a public
system and one nice thing that you
should obviously see is depending on
what gradient method you use you can get
stuck quite early this is typical
because again I'm doing a gradient
search I'm not exploring the likelihood
of the parameter space I merely looking
for the most optimal one and there's
risk involved as well
so yeah but the whole two steps back
again if you're doing a gradient search
again you're interested in a very likely
value one such value in this case I'm
interested in the distribution Socastee
gradient descent also means that there's
a stochastic City in calculating the
gradient not so much in finding the
crank posterior you of course hope that
a good stochastic gradient descent and a
good sound ler reached a similar
conclusion that doesn't sort that
supports one another this however
doesn't have to be the case especially
if you get thousands of parameters hi
great talk thank you and if you go to
the plot where you show the search
problem this point you here's one or the
second one and I have to pursue any of
them so I press this button - yeah the
the no not this one I believe you mean
this one yeah I would like with the
switch but yeah that one's yeah so I can
see that this is something useful to
kind of the tech regimes right in time
series data potentially so what
happening from what I can see here is
that your your mu and your Sigma a kind
of constant or have a mean value right
so obviously that's an assumption in my
model right there are more mature ways
of dealing attack you have 2000 ask
either can these be applied as well when
you don't have necessarily like to
consume you Sigma but you know you have
a thrifty in your time series yeah so
there's some ways of dealing with it but
that's sort of the arts of being the
Bayesian I will first show the math and
then come back to this because the whole
models is here how I relate this switch
point to any model I could also say the
front bitten in the back bit they're
both different linear regressions and
then I have a switch point and there's a
constant and a slope on that end and
there's a constant and a different slope
on this end I have to do you know I have
to be kind of careful that I do the math
well but you can do whatever system you
want here the sample will just figure
out with given this system what are
likely parameters and how certain are we
of them okay so modeling step is here
for example here I'm saying
from a normal distribution and that's it
but I can also say well you know this
comes from W is a normal distribution
where it's w0 plus w1 times whatever
time step and there's also some
uncertainty there and you have to do
more modeling let's say but you still
have the full flexibility if people are
interested in this they come up if
enough people wanted we can do it on
conference and I'll show you some more
demos of this but typically you have
full freedom in that sense what you
could even do is you can say hey here's
one instance with this system use a
different system use a different system
and then find the most optimal
parameters for that one system and then
compare the likelihood of all these
systems because the system itself also
gets a likelihood parameter thank you
good thing we have like eight minutes
for questions
nice I think in pints III that I'd say
the most popular default sample would be
no u-turn so this so first of all yes
there's multiple ways of sampling of
course the way the pebble jumps you can
do that in different ways for example if
this is a two-dimensional space I can
jump directly to a new place but I can
also first jump in the X direction and
then in the Y direction but there's also
many different ways that you could
sample and times III just have support
for lots of ways of doing that right now
that's all I don't have this answer your
question because I interrupt you but
look at the move but I I was applying
inference in my mind to figure out what
you were here yeah hi there's a really
great talk
how similar would the distribution be
for the parameter values if you just
used bootstrapping instead of this
approach so it does feel similar right
and so typically what you could do for
bootstrapping for example just a nice
exercise as well is you can say take a
subset of the regression that I'm doing
find the most likely value for the slope
and your insteps take a different subset
repeat repeat repeat repeat so I so one
would immediately assume yet it has to
be some form of similarity and it's just
that the sampling methods are slightly
different so the convergence times would
probably be a bit different also
depending on how you sample the
bootstrap you might have more or less
bias if you sample only five points for
exam
I would assume that it's reasonably
similar you convergence and there's all
these numerical things that can go wrong
but it feels like it should be similar
the dis approach is more performant
would you say hard to say the thing is
this approaches me so my argument for
this is this is very flexible
I can paralyze this right I can just
well boots up we can do that too but I
can do whatever mathematical system I
want and whereas for the bootstrapping
system you still need to be able to do
ok data model do a gradient search one
point and different data model one point
whereas here I just say ok system sample
it's a again I believe the results
oughta be is somewhat similar because
you're doing it's similar thing you're
trying to do some form of inference so
it'd be very surprising if the
bootstrapping approach we see a
completely different conclusion in this
see I'm assuming that converges to the
same spot it's just that I'm not the
most formal guy when it comes to mass so
thanks very much if there are no more
questions and I think it's might be nice
to do some patience for district wentest
jokes y'all ready what's the downside of
doing a Bayesian what is the downside of
being a Bayesian you have to explain
your priors very frequently another
question what's the downside of being a
frequentist why does the cuantas always
make mistakes because of a quaintest has
no prior knowledge thanks guys
[Applause]
you
[Music]